financial markets in russia had been
volatile for weeks leading up to the
country's invasion of ukraine and we saw
a sell-off after the u.s and numerous
other industrialized nations imposed
sanctions on russia when it moved into
the sovereign nation one of the most
significant results of all that has been
the historic loss of value for russia's
currency the ruble i'll explain why that
is how it works and what it could mean
for russia and its conflict with ukraine
going forward first let me explain why
the value of russia's currency is so
important currencies are traded on
markets just like stocks or other
investments where investors decide every
day what a country's dollar or peso or
ruble is worth when a country's economy
improves typically its interest rates
rise and it attracts outside money so
the value of its currency increases when
the economy slows down the central bank
is usually cutting interest rates in an
effort to improve things and the value
of the currency typically falls a weak
currency makes it expensive to buy
imports because many are priced in
dollars so even if the price of an item
doesn't change when a currency loses
value it costs more for that country's
citizens to buy that also raises
inflation and creates problems for
businesses russia's currency has been
losing value since 2014 when russian
president vladimir putin decided to
invade crimea and face sanctions from
the united states european union and
others
one u.s dollar bought around 32 russian
rubles at the beginning of 2014. by the
end of 2019 it was about 62 rubles at
the start of 2022 one dollar was worth
around 73 rupees then came the invasion
of ukraine
sanctions from the u.s europe and others
and the removal of russia's access to
the swift global payment system that is
big my colleague shelby holliday has a
great video about swift what it is and
why it matters i've left a link to that
video in the comments check it out if
you want to know more economic sanctions
like the ones imposed on russia are
orders by countries that ban their
companies or financial institutions from
doing business with firms based in the
sanctioned country the sanctions imposed
so far largely stopped the flow of
european and american money into much of
russia's financial system that can choke
off a country's economy because its
businesses simply can't do business with
large portions of the world's financial
system the ruble fell to a record low
value of 85 to 1 versus the dollar after
the invasion and to more than 100 rubles
per dollar in the following days in
addition to boosting inflation a weak
currency also causes capital flight
investors pull their money out of the
local currency and put it in one scene
as more stable typically dollars or
euros in response russia has imposed
capital controls and its central bank
has raised the country's interest rates
to more than 20 percent this could be
the start of a vicious circle high
interest rates means it's more expensive
to borrow money which slows down the
economy and rising inflation makes goods
and services more expensive and harder
to obtain this is the goal of sanctions
hurt a country's economy so much that
its leaders decide to change their
actions in this case that means pulling
back on the invasion of ukraine however
russia still has a massive stockpile of
dollars euros and gold and it also
provides about 12 percent of the world's
oil so it's unlikely that russia will
fold overnight outside of russia this
turmoil hasn't undermined investors
confidence while stock prices have been
hurt by the conflict u.s and european
markets haven't seen anything like the
sell-off in russian assets currencies
tell an important story an investor
should watch the ruble if they want to
see how much better or worse things are
getting in russia if you enjoyed this
video hit the like button and make sure
to subscribe to keep up with my latest
videos on markets and finance i'll see
you next time